hey I'm Jasmine you might know me from
BuzzFeed bring me Zion boo time I'm a
huge foodie I cook all the time and food
is just a huge part of my identity and
something I learned recently was sell by
dates you know when you buy food at the
store and it has those little date
labels on them those labels are called
sell by dates and the way I've operated
my entire life is that if that day had
passed
I threw the food away no questions asked
to better myself I decided to tackle
this learning in a very real and public
way by only eating food that has safely
gone past its sell-by date for 72 hours
that's everything from canned food to
dairy to vegetables to even tea but
before I jump into this adventure I want
to make sure that I'm not going to be
consuming anything that will make me
sick or miss inform the world so I'm
heading over to UCLA to meet with dr.
Katherine carpenter who has a PhD in
nutrition to learn more Katherine I'm so
excited to be here I have so many
questions so first question when did we
start putting sell-by dates on food well
the whole idea about providing dates was
actually a movement started by consumers
in the 70s and the food industry picked
up on this it's been quite successful as
far as giving the consumers a time frame
to make sure that the food will be fresh
but on the other side it's also causing
a lot of food waste I'm guilty of that I
feel like I cost a lot of food once I
see that it's past the sell-by even
though I will look at it I'm like it
might still be good but I have a
sensitive stomach so I just don't want
to take that risk
so how strictly should I follow the
sell-by date guideline it's a message
from the food industry to the retailer
telling them to pull the food off the
shelf so it isn't necessarily the date
when the food goes bad these dates are
designed really to protect the public
and they're not fixed so in other words
you do have a little more time
afterwards
are there certain foods that I should
really avoid eating past its sell-by
date perishable foods so things like
meat and dairy these foods can go bad
they come from living tissue you want to
be more careful
about the dates and you want to make
sure that you prepare them quickly
and/or you store them properly and or
you freeze them right away and that's
very different from foods like cereals
or pastas those foods
they've already been prepared they're
basically pretty dried out and the worst
thing that can happen is they'll go
stale also what's the other way to tell
if meat is good or not you you smell it
you look at it if it smells rotten
whatever the date is unfortunately
you'll have to let it go you know it's
important I think for the public to
develop more awareness about how much
power they have in their own life
actually to make a difference okay so
taking that all into consideration
what's your biggest advice as I go into
the next 72 hours eating food past its
sell-by date let's have the idea that
the food's gonna taste good and let's
you know just prepare it as though there
was nothing wrong with it hopefully I
could do that and I could reduce my
waste and also become a better consumer
in the future so when I went through my
entire cabinet and I found like one or
two things past the sell-by date and I
thought hmmm I don't have a lot of
things but you know who does Asian
mothers so I came to my mom's house
she's not here right now I'm gonna raid
her entire cabinet and take out all the
things that are past the sell-by date
I'm pretty positive there's gonna be a
bunch soafter grocery shopping at my
mom's house this is what I have this
cough cookies best buy August 26
2019 miso soup base July 8 2019 some
rock sugar best by 2016 and black bean
sauce mix otherwise known as Dedham best
before September 27 2019 there's a lot
of good stuff here I think they're still
good I kind of sniff some I think I'm
gonna be able to easily make these meals
yeah everything's not going to waste
good morning it's day one of eating
foods past its sell-by date I have my
celery which has passed its best by date
of about four days
gonna make some celery juice to kick off
my morning and I think it'll taste great
but we'll see
Cheers I love celery juice it's day one
lunch time I have these noodles they
actually expired in 2018 and it's an
open bag but I smelled it and it smells
fine usually I can smell when it's gone
stale but this one doesn't smell stale
so I finished making my lunch it's using
the expired noodles from 2018 and on
tapas that's one style boiled fish and
topped with green onions and white
pepper mmm
oh my gosh so good if those noodles got
thrown away I would have been so sad the
Sun it's dinner time for day one I'm
going to be making black bean noodles
with steak squash and onions I don't
have noodles because I already ate my
spire and you know that I don't have new
live at home so I'm making them that's a
nice noodle this is a good noodle so
this black bean sauce is best before
September 27 2019 it's never been opened
so I think it should be okay actually
did this sauce expired a year ago oh
okay but it was like powdered there's
like dry sauce yeah and it was not an
open package I've been eating expired
food or food past its best buy and sell
by date all day and my butthole is fine
can you dig it yeah mmm so good I wish
everything expired good taste like this
mm-hmm YUM morning it's day two of the
challenge and this morning I'm gonna
have some miso soup instant miso soup
her breakfast and this one was best
before July 8 2018 I think this was
really best before july 2019 I think
that really strong miso flavor is gone
maybe put too much water now I'm at this
moral dilemma where I'm like to waste or
not to waste all right I'm making the
decision to toss this because at the end
of the day if you're eating food past
its sell-by date I think it's best to be
safe dr. Catherine said have taste it to
smell it and if it doesn't feel right
then it's probably best to throw it out
and so that's what I'm gonna do the miso
soup does not taste good this is the red
bean the date on here is March 9th 2019
so nearly a year past its best by
expiration Saul by day I don't know not
sure it doesn't really specify and I
also have sweet potato starch this one
is only past this date by a month or so
this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna use
the sweet potato starch mix it in with
some steamed sweet potatoes and make
some sweet potato rice balls and then
I'm also going to use the red beans as a
topping for a shaved ice I'm gonna make
lastly we're gonna add the grass jelly
and then we're gonna add some condensed
milk I made sure you guys yeah all that
work for the hit well it's worth it cuz
you know what
mmm I'm happy this was worth getting a
stomachache for the miso soup this
morning mmm
good morning it's the final 24 hours of
eating food passes sell-by date sober
day 3 I stuff a lot of things to use
that I haven't used and I'm not gonna
let them go to waste so I'm gonna do a
lot of cooking today for breakfast I'm
gonna start out with a smoothie bowl
topped with hip hearts and this was best
before July 2018 mm-hmm
oh good texture hmm okay time for like a
midday snack many of these discs are
cookies that were best before August 26
2019 mmm smells good next and brown
sugary
mmm Justin last meal with these foods
past is date on the packaging I've gone
with these two items for tonight quick
grits and steel-cut oats the steel-cut
oats were best before November 10 2019
and the quick grits were best before
April 26 2019 so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna make the grits of garlic
butter grits and for steel-cut oats I'm
gonna process these and turn them into a
batter so I can use it as the crust on
your fried cod and then I'll eat that
with the side of asparagus mmm I guess
that's 72 hours of eating foods that
stores probably wouldn't sell and I'm
still alive I think I made some pretty
good meals too if everyone in the world
knew what the words on their packaging
actually meant we could be wasting a lot
less food this was fun
this was good this really challenged me
the orders gonna be much happier now
because I will change my habits
[Music]
you
[Music]